maurepas et l'encours est peut-être
coignières incertitudes liées à la
démission du conseil municipal de cette
dernière commune avec une possible
remise en cause de sa participation dans
le projet de centre aquatique
intercommunal face évidemment à
l'instabilité politique de la ville de
coignières avec de nouvelles élections
municipales
il est préférable d'attendre en tout cas
que le conseil municipal de coignières
plus se prononcer sur une sortie
éventuelle de ce projet mais en tout
état de cause nous souhaitons poursuivre
l'aventuré à deux pour ne pas perdre de
temps sur ce beau projet un projet
réalisé à travers une concertation des
habitants
un toboggan aquatique un bassin ludique
ou encore un espace bien-être et forme
les activités sollicité par les
personnes interrogées
certains restent dubitatifs aujourd'hui
on lui présente une concertation qui a
eu via internet mais qui est en
définitive sur les peintures les
toboggans sur du cosmétique
il ya des inquiétudes à avoir parce que
peut-être que la forme qui a été choisi
de confier au privé
cet équipement ne permettra pas de
répondre à l'ensemble des besoins du
service public
une gestion à travers une délégation de
service public auprès d'une entreprise
privée
un dispositif voulu par les élus des
communes associées
le fait d'introduire le privé dans la
construction l'exploitation la gestion
et la maintenance d'équipements est un
gage de sécurité pour les collectivités
mais aussi une possibilité pour elle de
continuer à investir dans d'autres
équipements et pas uniquement pour
l'équipement aquatique
le public va rester acteur autant au
niveau de l'investissement y compris
d'ailleurs avec des cofinancements par
le département et la région et saint
quentin en yvelines
prochaine étape le lancement de l'appel
d'offres pour désigner l'opérateur les
travaux devraient débuter à l'été 2010 9
pour une ouverture prévue en 2021